[Music]
what's up my baby this is episode 195
of congratulations
[Music]
we're in it we're in it it already
started
it's the moment that when you saw that
thing
happen where the [ __ ] video got
uploaded
and then you got excited and now
it's playing the show congratulations is
playing
and i'll tell you what it's
uh it's not gonna get better than that
moment
the moment of excitement is the best
before the moment rips
it's like going to las vegas what's you
remember going
when you think about all the times you
had in las vegas what if you went to las
vegas 10 times you remember one dope
time that's not enough
that percentage is bad even for a a
major league baseball hitter
okay you understand and
the times you remember are driving there
here we go that's like the movie
swingers they did it perfectly so
look i'm gonna try and just ride that
moment as hard as i can
um i said i'll tell you what every time
i say i'll tell you what
actually every time i say i tell you
what i think of my friend who used to
who had this
he had this like um
phase of his life where he would say
well i'll tell you what and then say
something and he would do it all the
time
and this lasted for like two years he
really wrote out that i'll tell you what
phase
and one time
we were on our way to las vegas
and and he was doing it a lot
and i said something and he said
well i'll tell you what
and then said nothing after that
and i s and i had that moment right
there where i was like am i gonna let
this
fly am i gonna let him just have his i
tell you what
moment because that's his thing or am i
gonna call him on it
because what are you gonna tell me
so i said uh
what and he says nah
just ch
that was the birth of chris y'all that
was what made me realize
you call somebody out on their [ __ ] and
you get [ __ ] back
right but we [ __ ] it's
on dude it is so on and we're firing on
all syllables and dude
i said firing on all syllables and i do
that because it's better
okay not
firing it firing on all cylinder
cylinders dude
i'm not a a [ __ ] uh uh
ford truck uh i'm not a what i'm not a
hemi
am i a dude do i do i look like a
[ __ ] hemi to you no so i'm firing on
all syllables and people in the comments
are like you said syllables
it's cylinders oh it is you got four
wheels
you got a drop top are you exposing the
titties
no so we're firing on those syllables
because i'll tell you what
um what's up man
another thing i'd like to draw to
address is
i'll give you two i'll give you two
answers for this hey chris
and i get this question a lot are you
aware
actually you know what i used to get
this a lot do you shave your arms
the answer is no and i wish i did
so i could look right into the [ __ ]
camera and say yeah i shave my [ __ ]
arms
and be bowed about it but that doesn't
really happen that much anymore what
happens now is chris
are you wearing lipstick and i wish i
was dude
i respond to those comments sometimes
then i see i will and i say i wear
lipstick all the time
but i'll tell you what though instead of
that your boy's just got really red
pouty good model lips that's what i
that's what i have that's my that's what
my cross to bear is
my lips look like they i don't even have
that [ __ ]
that uh archery that bow that i don't
have that bow that people have
my lips don't meet my lips met already
the one lip on the top already met
itself from this one side to the other
side
they're not at the same coffee shop
they're already in bed together
i got that perfect circle model type
mouth
so sue me dude but that's what's up man
and i i just have red lips dude people
people walk down the street they go like
that's johnny red lips right there dude
that's me
and they're always wet because i stay
talking dude
i keep spitting my fiance says you don't
actually have to say all that stuff
and i go then why are my lips so red
we got to keep them red
my lips stay red and they will continue
to stay red
they look chapped as [ __ ] with lipstick
on them but nah never that dude just
regular skin
it is what it is and it will never be
what it is not
um yeah man
so go ahead man talk about the lipstick
i'm wearing
bobby lee brought it up why are your
lips always wet and one time my friend
said
one time i asked my friend straight up i
said what was the first thing you
thought when you ever
when when you met me and that's a very
egotistical question to ask people
but uh i should do it more often to be
honest
but i said what was the first thing that
you thought when you met me and
before i got done with the word me he
said your lips don't match your face and
i
[ __ ] laughed so hard because i agree
with him and that's fine
and that is fine
it's good dude it's good to not have
your lips match
your [ __ ] face especially when you
got that no beau perfect circle
type you know what i mean i stayed
disrespectful not only am i
drinking disrespectful on this podcast
i'm doing it with box water not because
i'm trying to save the planet
because i want to show you how [ __ ] it
is to drink at a box walk they thought
i'll tell you what man i'll save the
planet
if you help me out and don't make me
look like a [ __ ] when i'm drinking
water
that's so [ __ ] and this is how
respectful this is how
respectfully disrespectful i am i got a
coaster because wifey wants the coaster
here
boom coaster's here drink goes there
checkmate i got a coaster i don't even
use it okay we're off
to a firing on all syllables start let
me take it back a little bit
okay let me just relax because this
isn't all [ __ ]
it's like the stock market a podcast has
to be like the stock market
if the podcast is just like if it's like
a you know what i mean
if you're doing a podcast and it takes
the [ __ ] off like a gi joe airplane
where it just goes up and there's no
runway
get out of town dude you can't listen to
that for a [ __ ] hour and 10 minutes
um
so it goes up and down it's like the
stock exchange you know what i mean
and uh so let's just you know let's take
it back a little bit i saw a guy with a
shirt today that said go big or go home
and he was he looked
uh like he had a very unhealthy
lifestyle so
it was uh not okay for him to wear that
shirt or
because go big or go first of all go big
or go home is [ __ ] stupid
sometimes go medium honestly sometimes
sometimes stay out a little bit and also
go medium
you can go big or go home but not all
the time that whole go big or go home
thing
comes from the guy that's like dude you
go big you go home
every second of every [ __ ] day but
don't do that
go medium and sometimes stay out
i gotta make that shirt go medium and
sometimes stay out
but this guy had the shirt on just
because
he had the shirt on do you know what i'm
talking about and i do love guys like
that
it's [ __ ] hysterical man when a guy
just has a shirt on just because
that's a guy that gave up and it's fine
to do that because
you don't need to be focused on fashion
but my favorite type of guy
that does that is like dude the there is
a
race of people that will wear a hat
just to wear a hat and those are
mexicans
and that is the most [ __ ] hilarious
thing to me
that a mexican guy will just wear like a
san jose sharks ball cap
and not have a [ __ ] clue what hockey
is
it is so [ __ ] true
it is so true and i'm talking about any
style of mexican too
they'll just pop on and they'll be like
what's that [ __ ] i don't care i
[ __ ] it's sunny
with the two [ __ ] hockey sticks and
the shark coming out of it
oh you're a sharks fan okay
oh man mexicans love wearing some
baseball hats that they don't give a
[ __ ] about
and it's the truth dude why would you
listen to npr when i'm telling you the
facts
now let me tell you i should have
started like this dude thank you so much
for subscribing
to the it really and i and i and you
know what i went back on my mind
i went back on my mind when i [ __ ]
this guy left a comment on my youtube
and he was like you know what you
shouldn't you definitely shouldn't say
subscribe
upfront you should let them listen to a
little bit and then
suggest subscribing because they already
know then
after a while if they like the video or
not and then they'll do it
and i wrote to the guy and i said
no because i only like to do what i want
to do and i don't want to do that
and i and i [ __ ] wanted to start out
with this
and i didn't because i forgot and now
i'm pissed off i didn't because
the guy's right i did what the [ __ ]
guy wanted and i didn't want to do what
the guy wanted
so turn around and fart on that [ __ ]
subscribe button dude
hit that subscribe button and and
[ __ ] just
turn around and fart so hard
that a little bit of [ __ ] particles come
out on that [ __ ] like button as well
it helps
it helps dude it helps the algorithm you
know what make friends in the [ __ ]
comments
people out there are talking [ __ ] in my
comments people out there are being nice
in my comments somebody might be nice
and then somebody might disagree with
them
somebody might start shitty and then
somebody else might say you know what
that's actually just your opinion man
and the other guy's like well yeah
comedy's subjective and then the other
guy might be i mean bro i see these
comments guys going back and forth they
don't even know each other
they're making [ __ ] friends in the
comments go make friends in these
[ __ ] comments
right now make friends don't just
comment willy nilly
say hey anybody here from tucson
do you want to go to a [ __ ] a cuban
restaurant where they [ __ ] slice
slice off the meat at your table dude i
don't want any of that [ __ ]
when you go to those cuban restaurants
and they're like you're gonna do a cuban
is it cuban where they do that
where they show up and the the with the
chicken and the skewer
and they slice it all for you and if
you're from the midwest you go
no really here [ __ ] that do it all in
the kitchen
and then saunder it on out
so anyway yeah you just i i appreciate
this
the [ __ ] patreon members and i'll
tell you what i also appreciate you
if you're not on my patreon i appreciate
you if you just
watch the youtube i appreciate you if
you just listen audibly
on the apple podcast or spotify or
whatever
you know so go go medium and sometimes
stay out
i wish i said that to the guy but if it
looked like maybe you know he had covet
or something
um
so yeah you uh but really take a minute
and just [ __ ] kind of like
do a [ __ ] pootie on that like button
that would help a lot
um it's good coffee it's the regular
coffee
[ __ ] yeah dude it's the regular coffee
with no flavor dude
my jaw still hurts and it's fine dude
i'm just living with the pain i'm just
gonna be living with the pain i got a
bite plate from the dentist
and it's not [ __ ] working and that's
how life goes and that's why [ __ ]
life
will always rip because you sit and day
to day
sometimes you got that [ __ ] if you're
a guy with a tmj disorder
you just [ __ ] keep ripping life every
single day you wake up with that pain
you go
god damn it but i opened my eyes though
what's under my head a pillow i'm doing
fine um
so yeah you get a lot of extra content
if you do sign up for the patreon though
so uh we
we love it we love it um
we did it dude we did it
we did it tick tock nation we did it
tick-tock tic-tac-nation
i got my first tick-tock compliment in
real life
i got my first [ __ ] tick-tock
compliment in real life dude
do you understand what that's like
that's like unplugging the back of your
[ __ ]
neck in the matrix with all that pink
goo all over you when you're in one of
those pods
i did it dude i [ __ ] did it
um guy comes up to me and he says hey
man love your stuff
on tick tock and i say what he was like
45.
um
my key map isn't even open dude yes one
fire didn't open up my computer and make
it the way i wanted to
oh yeah dude love when i have to open it
and then say the [ __ ] key
files done isn't gonna be on it for some
reason when i wanna hit it and have it
go
bile's done encountered error one
sound file one assigned key while keymap
whatever dude as long as we got the
[ __ ] one that matters
[Music]
didn't check the volume and i had to
adjust it while the [ __ ] first bar
was coming up
ah yes dude loving it loving it
we love it dude um
what else we got here though where's the
[ __ ]
we still got that okay good we got those
that's great amazing
so yeah he came up and he was like dude
i really like your tick tock stuff and i
said thanks
because that's it that's what i am now a
[ __ ] tick tocker dude
you see my [ __ ] on there go viral people
why is this [ __ ] on my for you
page thanks you just helped the
algorithm
this guy keeps showing up on my for you
page i don't want that
oh really well then why don't you block
me because it was
way easier to block me than it was to
type out all those words
[ __ ] yeah you're sitting at home like
dude i love it man
i love it uh
i'm a tick-tocker i'm a [ __ ]
full-blown tick-tocker
god man these [ __ ]
bro i was i want to know man
there's like a uh a channel on tick tock
oh it's so funny what what the [ __ ] is
everybody doing on tik tok if you're not
making fun of tick tock on tick tock
what are you doing on tik tok when the
people are just like
lipstick lips lip syncing looking at the
camera
oh and when dudes are doing it
oh i get it oh i oh i get it if you
oh i get it if you're shaped like an ass
but dudes are doing it
oh oh i get it if you
i get if you have an hourglass figure
but dudes are doing it
bro you're a v
not an hourglass choo
doon dudes are out there just like
pretending like they're [ __ ] uh
what's that country guy
morgan morgan whalen or [ __ ] bryce
hall i don't know no that's no bracelet
was the guy who is on tick
dude tick tock is a wealth of [ __ ] up
and i'm on it dude
see here's so the guy gives me a tick
tock compliment
compliment [ __ ] it i don't need all the
syllables
he gave me a tick tock complaint
and um it was nice
and i'm on tick tock actually my buddy
sent me this one tick tock dude
of these did there's there's the my
favorite ones are the ones where they're
like
there's like five dudes dancing
and they each take turns doing one lyric
of the song
[Laughter]
that's nothing yeah you're 18
and you're hanging out with the homies
and you all got the same haircut
where it's like flat here but then it
swoops up what is that [ __ ] haircut
that
every 18 19 year old dude has where it
swoops down
and it goes real low but right before it
becomes bangs
it's like nah instead
it goes up oh you thought this this is
what the hair's saying this is what the
hair is doing the hair's coming from
it's like the young donald trump with
the [ __ ] cotton candy [ __ ] that he
does to hide the bald spot
but it comes because it comes from way
back here and it's a wave
it's a wave like from that [ __ ] from
that movie
that came out at the same time that like
armageddon came out that i can't
remember the name because it wasn't as
good and wasn't as popular
uh but it [ __ ] was like that wave
that came that tsunami of hair
and it comes out and it's going like
this yo we bout to be bangs
and then it as it cat as it hits that cr
that lower crescendo
it swoops the [ __ ] up and it goes nah
no bangs
that hair [ __ ] sucks and i said i
wanted [ __ ] a dangly earring
way before this [ __ ] came back in
fashion for [ __ ] 19 year old dudes
and now i'm pissed because people are
gonna think i'm copying cause these
[ __ ] got dangly crosses
i gotta get some real [ __ ] now i gotta
get like [ __ ] a lug nut
or something [ __ ] i'm pissed dude
i need to get like a [ __ ] uh a a
link with a [ __ ] lace potato chip on
that
i'm pissed dude these boys got me
before i know that i know one of them
listened to my podcast
and they were like yeah guess what what
delia said he gonna get
a dangly earring oh really yeah let's
all get it instead
and let's all live in the same house
there's a thing there's like tick-tock
houses where they're in the house and
they just do tick-tocks
and sometimes they'll show like the side
footage of it
and it's like it's set insecure because
they like take turns where
they're singing the song and then they
move off frame and then another guy
comes in and does it
and then the goofy guy comes in it's
like the new version of a boy band only
you're not even doing the work
like somebody said to me he's like well
that's like the new boy band yeah but
they were at least
doing something
you understand
like if you if you can't even compare
yourself
to [ __ ] not even justin timberlake
but
jc chazy or joey fat one it's like come
on man
his last name is spelled fat one
you tried to trick me with fatone the
[ __ ] out of here
and he was the fat one
that's like one of the kids being named
[ __ ]
jim happens to be racist
are you racist know what makes you say
that no makes you say that
ting i ain't going to the south side of
any city
um so yeah these tick tockers dude they
got a house
my it's [ __ ] hysterical dude
they'll be like look
jim messed up the lyric at the end
or [ __ ] billy's face
wtf teaching nick how to dance
do some and here's the other thing
what about when you're
that's what you're not thinking of
tick-tocker
it's fine to be on tick-tock your boy's
on tick-tock your boy's
crazy on tick-tock your boy goes
s-stupid viral on tick-tock
your boy starts [ __ ] friendships in
the comments
i mean your boys [ __ ] stupid loco on
tick tock right
i'm locked out and like
you can beat will smith's on tick tock
and he's locked out too on tick tock
but bro when you're just doing the
[ __ ]
kevin go and cut it
jamie go
kent come on
poke in his eye can't poke desire at the
end
what are you doing when you're 45
and you have like a kid and the new [ __ ]
is the new [ __ ]
it's not tick-tock anymore that shit's
not cool anymore
and your kids like that why did you do
that with all those other guys that look
the same as you and
live in the same house and have those
[ __ ] dangly earrings that crystally
wanted
and they ruined that for him
kevin your turn thanks other kevin
what are these dance they're not even
dances dude
they'll do that one [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] i love it
and it's like to girl songs
come on in kent [ __ ]
wet ass [ __ ] come on ken
i kissed a girl and i like it kent
some guy named k ah for [ __ ] sake
what happens when you're 45 dude
that's out there bro
all i'm saying is don't [ __ ] you're
not that guy okay
you're not that guy you're not that guy
bro that guy that thing that went viral
this
this week you're not that guy pal trust
me you're not that guy
just total uncle energy you're not that
guy
you're not that guy that's [ __ ]
amazing how's that
how's that dude one time my uncle
said to my cousin my cousin was like
complaining about like yeah i don't know
i don't really want to go to college
this
was a high school and my uncle had this
energy and he just says
don't go don't go then don't go he
it's like that's the uncle energy is
like already right there
don't go and i you could tell like
they talked about it already so you
could tell like something already has
been happening in this
they're in a supermarket oh
how's that how's that how's that [ __ ]
you where you breathe
with his hands and his pockets
[ __ ] you where you breathe how's that
[ __ ] you where you breathe
how's that with his hands in his pockets
looking for change
[ __ ] you where you breathe rolling lint
around
couldn't be more casual telling the
guy's gonna [ __ ] his mouth
how's that unreal guy
[ __ ] un
real guys wearing the last remaining
union base shirt
don't tell me what the [ __ ] to do how's
that pal
don't tell me what to do how's that pal
still hands in the pocket bro
let me tell you right now you come at me
with that energy
and you have your hands in your pocket
i'm gonna knock you
in the face because it's gonna be so
easy
how about that somehow somehow though
i can tell that even though this guy is
at this level
and we have no context somehow i can
tell that this guy's in the right i
don't know why
i can tell but i can tell that this
guy's in the right
i didn't tell you what you did you said
don't talk to people who you don't know
i'll talk to whoever the [ __ ] i want to
know never mind how's that pal never
mind
another how's that dude when a guy's
angry
and calls people terms of endearment
like pal
forget it hey pal
what's going on pal [ __ ] your wig or
breathe how about that pal how's that
just rolling some lint around in my
pocket just looking for some quarters
how's that pal i'll [ __ ] you with your
breathe how's that
oh look found two pieces of lint look at
that
oh look got a got a straw wrapper i
realized i didn't i couldn't find a
trash can
so i put it in my pocket how's that pal
i found that in my left pocket and two
quarters and a dime in my right pocket
how's that pal
the [ __ ] your [ __ ] way to breathe
huh
mine i did tell him not to talk to you
that's right so use your [ __ ] head if
you know how
understood okay you little pimply little
[ __ ]
the illest slam i ever heard in my life
how's that your pimply little pimple
face [ __ ]
i've never heard a slam like that the
guy came guns
blazing dude
amazing
the checkout late uh could you guys just
not
maybe i'm what i'm doing is
like the wind blowing it's not affecting
anything
but i just i have to do this because
the wind has to blow so
that sounds good to me there's something
to leave i'm checking out sir
check it out ring out if you guys if you
could take it
you're not that guy pal trust me this
guy is like has the wally backman energy
where he [ __ ]
i gotta go back a little bit because
that's when he starts to say you're not
that guy that is just so gangster dude
you're not that guy pal trust me you're
not that guy okay yeah you
absolutely yep he is that guy can get
arrested for this arrested for doing
what
just like a pimple on the left somebody
says something and you don't like it
hey what does it mean
am i the dumb one here what does it mean
just like a pimple on the left man
somebody says something somebody doesn't
like it
legit had a [ __ ] aneurysm
right there right there had a stroke
when she was like and that there
remember the [ __ ] newscaster and that
their um and their um
they're um he's doing the he's the male
version of the
such as and such as uh what's a [ __ ]
pageant
that mario lopez tried to keep it
together with his [ __ ] beautiful face
just by smiling so how would you solve
world peace well such as such as
if you such as such as just as [ __ ]
[ __ ] is leaking from her anus just
malfunctioning i'm sorry i'm not that
guy
and you don't like it right is that what
it is you're a little
pimp can you hold the camera while i
check i'll leave the store
[ __ ] you where you blue you fell right
[ __ ] you where you bleed
where do you bleed
you can vote
oh jesus christ it's not cool to take
the lord's name in vain but okay
work for biden and suck right here pal
two things
now i showed you no shut up i don't want
to go
the thing is i didn't want another video
to play and you made it happen and i
didn't want that to happen
you're not that guy it's always a
[ __ ] video from like sky news what
the [ __ ] is sky news
um
oh dude if a guy came at me with that
energy
i can't even tell you
how much i would raise that energy
like you're not that guy
i would say oh yeah i am
and i get real close to him too
oh you're not that guy you must be
mistaking me
for not that guy
i mean d i get he was talking to [ __ ]
you know these
people who maybe don't deal with people
that much but bro
you talk you come up to me in a frozen
food section and tell me i'm not that
guy
you better believe i'm that [ __ ]
dude i'm 100
that guy
and when the guy says let's fight i say
dude we're not fighting we're [ __ ]
dancing hit it and then somebody plays
any camozy
here her up pick up the comes on the
area
put her up still leave it like that hey
you are not that guy
[ __ ] you where you breathe
work for biden suck my nuts
here comes the answer here comes the mad
trumpet what
a wrap pickle the movie on the area put
her up
i'll [ __ ] you will you breathe where are
you up
still living there yeah
the only union base should left in
existence
absolute pure uncle energy
hands in the pockets rolling lint touch
them up
touch them quarters and spend them
still leave it like that here come
he left with no groceries you know
that's the best
part you know in the car he was like
[ __ ] man i didn't even get my groceries
not that guy not that guy i didn't
get the [ __ ] goddamn milk my [ __ ]
wife's gonna be so mad i didn't get the
milk i'm gonna have to tell her i argued
with a teenager
well she better know he wasn't that guy
did you get the milk no i ran into that
i ran into not that guy
you know what happens i gotta only run
into that guy's
if i'm out there has to be those guys
around
if there are not that guy's around you
know what i do i know you get casual and
you start rolling lin
and the quarters at the time yes i
understand and you leave with no
groceries
but we need milk for the baby
go work for biden and suck my nuts
um
bro i want to i still want to talk about
the [ __ ]
why are why is how come
there is like a threshold of followers
that if you get
from nothing from from nothing like
followers beget followers like i'm not
talking about
all of a sudden david spade is on tick
tock and has two
has two million followers i'm not
talking about the david spades i'm
talking about
the people who just joined become viral
there's a
cap of followers you get where when you
reach it
you gotta start hitting a [ __ ] body
bag you gotta be a
you gotta start training to be a boxer
what the [ __ ] is that about
logan paul jake paul did it but what's
it about
that all these guys named bryce on tick
tock now have to do it
if there's a guy on bryce if there's a
guy on tick tock
named bryce with more than 2 million
followers
that dude is training as a boxer
why the one got punched the [ __ ] out was
it bryce hall
talking [ __ ] he was like i've been in 40
street fights who counts
their street fights you stop after three
you know you're like i think it was
40 street fights bro i'm a fighter and
then got
knocked dude he got knocked so hard his
hairline
you his hairline went back
he can't even do the [ __ ] swoop thing
anymore the
oops we ain't bangs no more
he got knocked the [ __ ] out and he is a
good sport about it afterwards he talked
to [ __ ]
it's the dick you got to get in the
boxers head i get it dude that's why
you're not that guy guy
was so [ __ ] he was in the other guys
you're not that guy
the other guy didn't want to be that guy
me oh yeah
i am oh oh i'm not that guy really then
why do i have a song
about being that guy hit it and then
[ __ ] dancers come out dude
um but man they [ __ ] these
[ __ ] make money but why is
boxing the thing you guys have to stop
boxing
aaron carter stop boxing
lamar odom you're too lanky
what are you doing jumping around
you don't even look good in a suit
you're too lanky don't just wear
up some boxing trunks and
fight aaron carter dude
i mean you're gonna [ __ ] touch him up
and go uh oh
that's not good dude nobody knows how to
box and we're all out here boxing
that's like of all of a sudden i trained
for [ __ ]
two months to be a [ __ ] opera singer
and then was like come on out everyone
that's better than these [ __ ]
youtubers out here throwing punches
man stop throwing punches just do those
dances
come on kent your turn ken comes in
i'm the silly one i'm not as good
looking as the other guy so i got to
stick my tongue out more
just [ __ ] bruises on the neck from
the cross the dangly cross [ __ ]
hitting it over and over again because
the cross is just like god [ __ ] god
i wish this [ __ ] would stop
banging me into his stupid white
neck
i'm getting a [ __ ] dangly frito chip
two nah one on the gay side
touch them up and go uh oh chi chiang
[Applause]
chang
so yeah dude stop fighting dude this is
a real sport you're going to get your
[ __ ]
you're going to get damaged dude
it's not cool it's not cool i know
you're making money and that's the other
thing too is like these [ __ ]
are giving
people money to do this [ __ ]
at least logan looked good man that
guy's really been training
jake he looked good take it serious
you know you've been in 40 fights who
gives you [ __ ] on the street
the [ __ ] it matter it doesn't matter
boxing is a sport
it is like it's like that's like being
like of course i can play
of course i can play cricket i've been
in 40 street fights
i challenge you to a game of badminton
i've been in 40 street fights
yes yes i want to enter the tetris
competition
i've been in 40 street fights
you're gonna get touched up and go uh oh
it's dangerous dude the parents are just
like oh my [ __ ]
you know
yeah man so
i got this [ __ ] shirt from uh
yeah advisory board crystals they sent
me they sent me a few items bro
they're the [ __ ] this [ __ ] company
you gotta go to
advisoryboardcrystals.com and check
their stuff out
uh it's just ill as [ __ ] and i'm wearing
it now
and uh they've been fans for a long time
so i just wanted to show my appreciation
to him
um yeah
i had i [ __ ] went to uh oh mascot
mask off dude
that's like that song from future mask
off but now for the kovid
mass off in la that's it you don't have
to wear a [ __ ] mask
so everyone was wearing their [ __ ]
masks i took off my [ __ ] richard
nixon mask i didn't wear it no
not once more do it i walked in this i
know i had the mask on i walked into
starbucks didn't know it was the day
where all of a sudden we could stop
wearing masks i
i swear to god dude i'm not bullshitting
you this is like a story my friend would
tell me and i'd be like ah [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourself
dude i walked in the starbucks nobody's
got their mask on and i'm like oh you
don't have to wear masks and the lady in
starbucks was like
now you don't have to wear masks anymore
we do because we work here and it's a
corporation
and we don't want to get sued but you
can just and i go like this wow
and i took my mask off and as i'm taking
my mask off
i'm my eyes are moving because my whole
head's moving and
as it moves it locks on two people
in starbucks making out
and not just making out mugging down
like really doing the real like
the kissing when you you really like
someone
when you're like i don't just like the
kiss i like the way they smell
they were mugging the [ __ ] down in
starbucks
and i was just like oh this is how it is
now
this is how [ __ ] ecstatic everyone is
you know they were trumpers just like
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] them
and stopped saying uh you know people
somebody said something about political
you don't know i don't
[ __ ] think about politics dude i
don't give a [ __ ]
i don't care i know i
look i've identified with being liberal
most my life
i know biden can't complete a sentence
so don't come at me and be like yeah but
your guy
he's not my guy you're not that guy
you're not that guy these people were
all good people at one point and then
got put into the system
and now i believe with the conspiracy
theorists that they're all holograms
i was a boy um
yeah dude just whatever man
i talked you know what i talk about a
lot of [ __ ] on this podcast i talk about
jokes
and sometimes i talk about real [ __ ] and
sometimes i do a blend of both you know
what i mean
i mix it it's the best of both worlds
sometimes you know it's like pasta and
it's like you know what it's like dude
[ __ ] strawberry ice cream and
pretzels
you ever have that [ __ ] you you ever had
that [ __ ]
right now you're probably like yuck try
it [ __ ]
try strawberry ice cream which i don't
even like
and pretzels which ain't popcorn
pretzels ain't popcorn in my book dude
you go to the movies what you get they
got pretzels there too
you get popcorn put pretzels
in strawberry ice cream
so i guess technically that's the best
of both worlds that's like medium worlds
coming together and making a better
world but what i'm
saying is
i did this whole thing and i got this
bit and i've talked about it on the
podcast for a lot
for a few episodes when somebody says
when you shake hands with somebody
and you don't really remember because i
meet a lot of [ __ ] you know and
when you talk to me meet them and
they're like and you're like oh hey
how's it going oh hey chris and then
they're like you don't
you don't remember me huh and then i go
and i say not that's not my fault that's
your fault
be more memorable and it's hardcore
you know because you boys been around
the block and met some people
you know
and it is a joke
but it's also something i've been
thinking about for a few weeks
and it's like you do have to be
memorable
there's some boring people out there and
i
feel like there's two ways of being
memorable right
there's the kind of memorable where
you're in a [ __ ] denim jacket sitting
in a podcast room
screaming about cargo pants with no
shirt on under the jacket
and sunglasses on at night doing karate
chops to water bottles
that guy you remember
and then there's everything in between
and then there's the person
that i want to be you know what i'm
talking about
like i remember this kid corey in my uh
elementary school that was
nice to me when nobody else was
i was a [ __ ] loser kid uh up until i
got cool
because i got cool dude
but i was a loser kid and i remember
corey made me feel good and i never
forgot
corey because that [ __ ] was
memorable and he was memorable because
he was a good guy now i don't know that
guy could be a [ __ ]
serial killer at this point i have no
idea what he was
but to me that dude i remember
i want to be that guy as an adult
i was referencing me obviously that was
one of the [ __ ] podcasts i did
shirt off with a chicago denim jacket
and gucci sunglasses on at night karate
chopping water bottles
nowhere close to a dojo
and
there's a lot of people in between and
there's a lot of people in between
because it's safe and it's easy to just
chill but you've
got to [ __ ] make people remember you
do you know why because you're gonna die
that's why you're gonna die
and the only people that are gonna
remember you are the people
that you become this guy to
and i've been thinking about that a lot
because there's substance here and
there's just
wackiness here you know
like there was a guy named chicken in uh
the comedy world in like the 90s at the
just for last festival
and he was like the talk of the festival
he would come out on stage and act like
a chicken
and everyone thought he was [ __ ]
hilarious and he got this [ __ ]
biggest deal out of jfl
and he was acting like a chicken and
everyone remembers him
that guy [ __ ] committed suicide it's
really sad
getting your mind right is important you
know staying healthy
making sure people [ __ ]
it doesn't matter if people like you but
you have to try to make
yourself better for th for yourself so
anyway
uh i'm tony robbins
uh yeah that was [ __ ]
uh you know
what i'm trying to say is go big or go
home
remember the [ __ ] did you guys see this
this has 26 million views so yes you've
seen it but let's talk about this for a
second
this is the real life liam neeson
i love this video it's dash cam footage
of a cash van crew under attack
from robbers okay this is like the [ __ ]
where you're like
does this really though does it really
happen like this is the real life liam
neeson here
i think this is south africa the real
life
liam neeson and
did this there's two dudes there's a
white older dude which is
if this was the movie it would be the
real life liam neeson and then there's
the younger black dude
and and it was literally the fir the
guys like first
drive or first week in
working and and this would the guy who
is playing this
younger black male would be
like the and introducing
a an actor you know what i mean it'd be
like
liam neeson and also there's this guy
that we're introducing just so you know
we're woke
and it would be like some [ __ ] movie
but
the the way they deal with it is awesome
they're driving they're just driving
they're driving that money van dude
and i think a minute in let me go to a
minute in
it's a normal day dude
looking in his side mirror i don't know
if he notices something's up yet
side mirror
car passes
a minute five in the video there it is
guy goes swerves swerves
[ __ ] fill up to the rookie
rookie says nothing i know
for a fact i know for a fact
if i was in you know people like well
you don't know how you'd react
if i wasn't driving if i was in the
passenger seat
and that happened to me for a fact i'm
not trying to be funny
this is what i would be saying okay okay
okay okay okay
that's what i would be saying that's
pretty [ __ ]
but i would be saying it calmly like
okay okay okay okay i'd be like joe
pesci and leave the weapon for
okay okay okay okay okay okay that would
be me all right
you got your gun he says
the rookie picks up the small gun he
goes this one it gives him the [ __ ]
the one that like you can't even hold in
a
in a car he's like this and it's [ __ ]
sticking up
he can't stick it under his arm because
then he'll literally be you can't open
the windows
because they're designed like that
because they're bulletproof and you're
not supposed to
open the window so they can't even open
the window and fire out of it they have
to open the door and fire out of it
which is something that i know
because i'm smart and you didn't know
that because you're [ __ ] stupid
sorry i i i sometimes i hate telling you
the truth
swerving again because he almost hit a
[ __ ] car that stopped
boom hits a car you know why he hits a
car
because it's because it's crazy right
now that's why that's all i can say
because it's [ __ ]
swerving all over the place shot out the
tire
i found out later the tire was shot out
liam neeson kept driving
an introducing young actor still holding
the gun
up like that it's pointed to his thigh
you know
because the guy can't stick it out the
window and he's calm as
[ __ ] dude they're both killing it
i would have said okay 47 times so far
no [ __ ] that i would have called
everybody up my mom my fiance
facetime hey guys sorry we're getting
shot at i just want to pass the phone to
pass the phone to mom dad pass the phone
to my dad
dad it's facetime so you don't have all
i see is your ear pass it
pass it to mom dad just look at the
camera god damn it
pap
you're on fate then my mom like this can
you hold it up a little bit so you don't
look like jabba the hutt please
it's back i just see what your mom i
could just see rachel maddow on the tv
hit it so it [ __ ] flips back your way
now they're in a park dude they pull off
bro the end of this let me just skip
forward to the end of it
they're trying to call their [ __ ]
people to get back up they can't do it
because the crooks
the robbers they have
[ __ ] cell phone scramblers like this
is
real [ __ ] they're getting scrambled
i can't do it i can't do it
gun still can't do it but just so you
know if
if my thigh acts up i can i can take him
out
i can take my thigh out right now if you
think my thigh is one of the bad guys i
just click it and
it it's uh we got it the guy just
like he's looking for someone at a party
they stop at a park
tire's gone crash into the robbers
can't reverse
i read about this so that's why i know
even though it's just showing the desk
but robert
ran away guy gets out of the car
runs after him with his [ __ ] ak-47
lost him
how different is that guy than you
that is insane dude those [ __ ]
kept calm and carried on
in a real [ __ ] as [ __ ] situation bro
and to think i couldn't mail my fiance's
[ __ ]
goddamn thing she wanted to
meet a male for [ __ ] six days
she was like can you mail that and i'm
like sure went out forgot
came back hey i told you to mail the
things can you oh sure
took them do they have [ __ ] mailboxes
anymore i'm asking you this
let's go back like this is pub fiction
let's start in the middle
so she asked me to take the mail but
let's i'm sorry that's
that's the beginning but let's go back
to the beginning
let's start from the middle are there
mailboxes anymore
i went to three different [ __ ]
mailboxes all around west hollywood
all of them boarded up no soldered in
i got out looking like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like the [ __ ]
people driving by ah you still think
there's mail i don't know
you're supposed to just electronic
[Music]
you're supposed to just forward it i
don't i don't know
i stopped at another one soldered shut i
stopped at
another one soldered shut
and i'm like i just got to go to a
[ __ ] mail place now dude i
i'm not bullshitting you i don't know if
that's true or not it sounds very untrue
it sounds like the government needs to
have mailboxes around but they're not in
weho man
where have all the mailboxes gone
so i'm like i gotta mail this letter
dude i go out for coffee every day i
probably drove seven or eight times says
i'm like i got these letters dude i hope
she doesn't see them
or i gotta come clean and be like i
haven't done it yet
but i got a package i got a package at
my p.o box
and i was like there it is i'm sorry
little kids
so that's the end of the episode on
youtube if you want to watch
the rest of the show sign up for our
patreon and support the show
patreon.com crystalia not only will you
get to see
the rest of this episode you'll get all
the backlogs of the patreon episodes
and other content that's hidden and
uh just things like that all sorts of
stuff and there's a discord that we all
chat on it's really fun
check that out patreon.com crystalia
thanks a lot guys
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that song